22h post scriptum la suite des aventures
théâtrales et musicales du ring saga en
création au théâtre de saint quentin
ce récital poétique pose ainsi la
question qu'est devenu le personnage de
wotan une fois sorti du ring de richard
wagner
la réponse et mène tout droit de
l'imaginaire et de l'histoire d'amitié
entre le metteur en scène antoine gindt
et le baryton à ivan ludlow évidemment
il continue sa vie d'artiste
une chanteuse choses et notamment à
partir de ce fils un peu banal on peut
tirer tout un tas d'histoires parce qu
est-ce qui chantent
et c'est là dessus qu'on commence notre
histoire à nous de savoir qu'est-ce que
ivan ludlow qui font wotan qui était
vendeur et maintenant comment il revient
avec quels fonds sont et de revenus la
relation fondatrice de ce projet qui lie
le chanteur et sa pianiste à la ligue
comme à la scène transporte ainsi le
public vers une authentique complicité
au delà d'un simple récital piano voix
le metteur en scène antoine gindt a
souhaité apporter une dimension plus
théâtral une forme revisitée mêlant
images et technologies la mise en scène
contemporaine très libre nous donne à
entendre pour la première fois en france
des poèmes de nietzsche mise en musique
sur des airs de wagner de rim ou des
mélodies décalé
évidemment quand on pense souvent
d'horreur on pense aux voyageurs et
canton pour sourds et à jeurre enfin
pour ma génération encore peut-être on
se dit tiens il ya une chanson qui
résonne à nos oreilles c'est celle de
riders on the storm des doors et on
s'est dit tiens comment on peut
introduire ce ce décalage je pense qu'on
a pour antoine gindt ce spectacle relève
surtout d'une certaine méditation d'un
voyage vers le cheminement de la pensée
en musique en représentation les 1er et
2 février au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines